alors il ya gad elmaleh mon ami gad
elmaleh qui m'appelle alors là lâche
beau dire en facetime en plus on va voir
ce qui fait mon garde mon frérot d'amour
salut mon gâteau ça va mon chéri savent
après roux tu es tu es en confinement et
ceux des quotes parts égales baba est ce
que tu es en race raoult est ce que ça
va coûter maison ouais je suis en
contact avec ma famille c'est bien donc
tu les vois pas tu t en juste en contact
dans les contacts temple et contactez
moi voilà c'est ça ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais et et c'est vrai qu'à
tous les gens qui sont chez eux et ça
fait du bien de voir voilà que gad aussi
est cheminot si on est chez nous
personne ne sort restez chez vous c'est
ce qu'ils ont dit il faut rester chez
soi sans vraiment combattre c'est un
truc de ouf qui arrive frérot tu
prépares ton prochain spectacle toi donc
c'est vrai qu'à faire plein de potes à
toi qui l'ont été sur scène qui ont dû à
arrêter leur spectacle tout ça c'est une
place pour tout le monde mais c'est vrai
que comme on disait avec matthieu
delormeau et gilles verdez mine de rien
on s'en fout de tout ça nous ce qu'on a
envie on se dit est ce qu'on va survivre
à ce qu'on va être bien de marée ce
qu'on va trouver des solutions pour que
les gens puissent voilà il n'est plus le
lait les plus touchées survivent
complètement son papa tu l'a répété
souvent ce ce qui ce qui nous est
d'ailleurs tout le personnel médical ont
dit pas assez
je le répète je pense je renvoie ce
qu'il regarde en ce moment
message ça leur fait un petit trou sans
leur folie donc ca de compans et pour le
reste on va pour le boulot qu'on va s'en
sortir il faut juste que les gens les
plus fragiles soit sauvé nos familles
nos parents les plus âgés d'enfin
efforts et on va s'en sortir on va vous
sortir et on va sortir tous ensemble en
tout cas je voudrais dire il a raison
d'être parce qu'il est on est obligé on
sera là tous les soirs pour rigoler
voilà frérot et nous il ya des sushis
qui arrive la cua montferrand sebha
entend moins 30 ans et 15 qui a un amour
de qui est toujours là mais pour aider
il a raison garder on essaie d'être là
pour vous faire rigoler aussi
donc si tu veux nous appeler tous les
soirs pour nous faire une petite d'arc à
une petite blague une titre dark athena
on est on est ouvert voilà on embrasse
tout le personnel aux pistes hospitalier
qui nous regarde et on va essayer de les
détendre un peu mais ils n'ont pas le
temps tellement de monde à nous regarder
mais bon on leur fait des gros bisous de
loin et on leur fait on leur envoie
plein du fort salut mon chéri d'amour au
thème mon thème qu'est-ce qu'il est
gentil
moi ce que j'aime là c'est la solidarité
la qui se passe en ce moment alors passé
de l'agressivité tous les jours c'est
insulter quelqu'un et je reçois beaucoup
de messages et c'est touchant qui te le
disais tout ça beaucoup de gens qui
disent effectivement la solitude
il se lève le matin seuls et prennent un
petit déjeuner seule une douche y
passent leurs journées seuls chez eux se
couchent seul c'est tellement dépressifs
qu'ils osent c'est horrible et voilà
qu'ils disent bah bravo pour ce que tu
fais les missions et tout ça et beaucoup
qui disent aussi que si tu enlèves ce
genre d'émission où il ya un petit peu
de divertissement
il ne reste plus que les chaînes d'info
en en bouc dessus et ça a un côté état
de guerre moi j'en fais plutôt francs -
tf1 ils sont mis les tuche dimanche soir
j'étais comme un fou fabre j'avais
l'impression qu'on m'avait dit ben ouais
j'attends l'acte dit la vérité alors
j'attends ce jeudi soir là il ya mon
pote là on va l'appeler demain
michaël youn je l'attendais rennes mais
si je comme un fou pour le regarder sur
m6 on a envie de se détendre aussi